.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
In dieser Sendung
treffe ich Menschen,
die erlebt haben,
was niemand erleben will:
Sie wurden zu Opfern.
(Frau)
Wir hatten so eine schöne Hochzeit.
Ich freute mich so,
mit diesem Mann zusammenzubleiben.
Ich hätte nie gedacht,
dass es so weit kommt.
In der vierten Klasse fing es an.
Man musste
einfach dabei zusehen ...
... wie man fertiggemacht wurde.
Man verzweifelt
am Schluss an sich selbst.
"Drei Tag vor Heiligabend
wurde ich vergewaltigt."
"Nicht von einem Fremden -
in den vier Wänden
eines 'Freundes'."
Der sexuelle Missbrauch ist etwas,
das man nicht vergessen kann.
Der psychische Missbrauch
ist eigentlich das Schlimmste.
Ich bete einfach jeden Tag ...
... das Vaterunser.
Dort steht, dass man vergeben soll -
und das versuche ich.
Dominik, es hat Ihnen nicht gefallen,
im Heim zu leben.- Nein.
Nicht?
Was macht es mit Menschen,
wenn sie so etwas erleben?
Wie kommt man wieder da raus?
Einmal Opfer, immer Opfer?
Wenn man an Gewaltopfer denkt,
denkt man an Bilder
von dunklen Gassen, von Tätern,
die uns irgendwo auflauern.
Aber viele Verbrechen
passieren ausgerechnet dort,
wo wir uns eigentlich
am sichersten fühlen.
Nämlich in den eigenen vier Wänden.
Es war eigentlich
eine perfekte Hochzeit.
Sie war wunderschön.
Was auffällt:
Da ist meine Nase noch gerade.
Jetzt ist sie ja
immer noch gebrochen.
Nur zum Sagen:
Sie war mal sehr gerade.
Wie oft ist die Nase gebrochen?
- Ich weiss es nicht.
Dreimal sicher.
Nach der Geburt.
Der gemeinsame Sohn - ein Wunschkind.
Als Tochter
eines Schweizer Diplomaten
war Corinne T.
auf der halben Welt zu Hause.
Ein Baby, ein Ehemann, ein Eigenheim.
Die Direktionsassistentin
schien endlich angekommen.
Wirklich gewendet hat es sich
bei der Geburt des Kindes.
Vermutlich habe ich mich nicht mehr
genügend um ihn gekümmert.
Er hat das aber nie geäussert.
Er hat nie gesagt:
"Was ist mit mir?"
Wie hat er das dann geäussert?
Mit Frust.
Alkohol
wurde zu einem grossen Thema.
Er ging öfters aus,
was mir nicht passte.
Dann schrie ich ihn an:
"Wo warst du?"
Er kam unter der Woche an
einem Dienstag besoffen nach Hause,
um 1 Uhr morgens. Dann fing es an.
Das ist der letzte Spitalbericht.
Da ging es wirklich um mein Leben.
Da steht auch:
"alkoholisiert,
mehrmals verprügelt".
"Gewürgt, mit Fäusten ins Gesicht
geschlagen" - das ist das.
"Übelkeit,
Erbrechen, Nasenbeinbruch", usw.
"Faust ins Gesicht".
Nach zwölf Jahren Ehehölle
gelang Corinne T. der Ausstieg.
Zusammen mit ihrem Sohn
flüchtete sie ins Frauenhaus.
Wir treffen die damalige Leiterin.
Alle zwei Wochen
stirbt in der Schweiz eine Person
infolge häuslicher Gewalt,
die meisten davon sind Frauen.
Die Scham, darüber zu reden,
ist bei Betroffenen, bei Opfern
von häuslicher Gewalt, sehr gross.
Warum?
Weil es beschämend ist,
dass einem selbst das passiert.
Gerade auch Frauen wie Frau ...
* Piepen *
die das nie in ihrem Leben ...
Sie dachte nicht, dass ihr
das jemals passieren könnte.
Ich hatte Staatsanwältinnen
als Klientinnen,
Ärztinnen, Psychologinnen,
Politikerinnen - alles.
Die glaubten nie,
dass ihnen das passieren könnte.
Wenn sie
nicht gleich gegangen sind ...
Wenn es
eine längere Zeit dauerte ...
... bis sie sich
daraus befreien konnten,
ist es unglaublich beschämend, dass
man das mit sich hat machen lassen.
Das ist eine Art Mechanismus.
Man will zeigen,
dass alles in Ordnung ist,
und man will
nicht als Versager dastehen.
Ich fühlte mich schon so,
als ob ich versagt hätte.
* Bedrohliche Klänge *
Was lösen die Bilder in Ihnen aus,
wenn Sie sie nun anschauen?
(Mit verfremdeter Stimme)
Was soll das auslösen?
Es zeigt ganz klar,
was für ein Arsch man ist.
Ich schäme mich derartig,
was auch mehr als recht ist.
Es ist nicht normal,
das macht man nicht.
Ein normaler Mensch
macht so etwas nicht.
Sie haben es gemacht.
- Ich weiss.
Ich weiss, dass ich es gemacht habe.
Das geht mir immer durch den Kopf.
Das Warum?
- Das Warum, das Wieso.
Was führte dazu? Wo hätte man
etwas anders machen können?
Auch für ihn
war es eine Liebeshochzeit.
Unerklärlich,
wie die anfängliche Zuneigung
schleichend zur Gewalt wurde,
ausartete.
Bis Corinne T. ihren Mann
nach einer brutalen Prügelattacke
schliesslich
bei der Polizei anzeigte.
Ihr Mann besuchte daraufhin
ein Gewaltprogramm.
Diese Massnahme
vermochte die Beziehung
aber auch nicht mehr zu retten.
(Mit verfremdeter Stimme)
Das Problem entsteht,
wenn man
die ganze Nacht terrorisiert wird,
bis in den frühen Morgen hinein,
bis sie sich
nicht mehr besinnen kann.
Nicht ich - sie.
Das können Sie sich
nicht vorstellen.
Das müssen Sie erlebt haben -
und zwar nicht nur einmal.
Das müssen Sie wiederholt erleben,
dann können Sie vielleicht
etwas nachvollziehen,
was da in einem vorgeht.
Es ist schon Gewalt, mich die ganze
Nacht nicht schlafen zu lassen,
nur damit es nach ihrem Kopf geht.
Aber es gibt doch eine Grenze,
ob man laut ist und streitet,
oder ob man jemanden schlägt.
Die Grenze gibt es ein Stück weit,
da haben Sie recht,
aber das Problem ist ...
Es heisst immer,
das dürfe man nicht.
Aber alles andere ist erlaubt?
Das sehe ich nicht so.
Das davor ist nicht erlaubt.
An den Haaren reissen
ist keine Zärtlichkeit -
apropos Gewalt.
D.h. nicht, dass Sie Ihre Frau
auch schlagen mussten,
bis zu einem Nasenbeinbruch, z.B.
Wenn sie mich angreift und mir eins
an die Nase haut oder sonst etwas,
dann muss ich mich wehren.
Haben Sie gegenüber Ihrem Mann
auch Übergriffe, Gewalt ausgeübt?
Nein, nie.
Körperliche Gewalt: nicht einmal.
Wir hatten natürlich
normale Streitgespräche.
Aber angefasst ... Ich habe ihn
vielleicht einmal geschüttelt.
Als er betrunken im Bett lag,
sagte ich, ich würde ihn verlassen.
Das habe ich gemacht,
ich habe ihn einmal geschüttelt.
Keine tätlichen Übergriffe?
- Nein.
Nie geschlagen. Nichts.
Nie.
Vielleicht
hätte ich mich wehren sollen.
Aber das hätte
verheerende Folgen gehabt.
Verheerende Folgen.
Schlussendlich
ging ich wegen zwei Wörtern.
Er drehte sich zu mir.
Ich weinte, war am Boden zerstört.
Magenschmerzen, alles.
Er schüttelte den Kopf und sagte:
"Kein Verlust."
Dann ...
Ich merkte:
Er hat nichts mehr für mich übrig.
Es wurde mir sehr klar,
dass ich ihm nichts wert bin.
Ja.
(Mann) Geht's?
Das ist anstrengend.
- Das ist Sport.- Ja.
So.
Vor gut drei Jahren lernte Corinne T.
ihren heutigen Partner kennen,
im Internet.
Eric Z. ist Polizist.
Bilder der Gewalt
kennt er von seiner Arbeit.
Was es aber konkret heisst, mit
einer Frau eine Beziehung zu führen,
die geprügelt und gedemütigt wurde,
ist auch für ihn neu.
Am Anfang war einfach
der Vertrauensaufbau sehr schwierig.
Ihr glaubhaft machen zu können,
dass ich es nicht böse meine.
Dass ich es ernst meine
und auch jemanden suche,
mit dem ich den Rest meines Lebens
zusammen sein kann.
Einfach jemanden zu haben,
ein Paar zu sein.
Das Bedürfnis hatte ich,
und ich werfe nicht etwas weg,
weil in ihrem Leben etwas passiert
ist, wofür sie nicht viel kann.
Man baut weiter.
Wir sind keine Teenager,
die sich gleich wieder trennen.
Es ist eine Belastung
für die Beziehung,
wenn das Thema immer da ist.
Irgendwann muss ich abschliessen,
aber es ist viel besser.
Werden Sie es einmal abschliessen?
Ja, aber ich werde es
nie vergessen können.
Es wird immer ein Teil von mir sein,
lebenslänglich.
Das war vor vier Jahren.
Ich bin jetzt bei Corinne T.
Den Nachnamen
lassen wir weiterhin weg.
Wenn Sie das wieder hören:
"Das wird mich
ein Leben lang begleiten."
Würden Sie das heute
immer noch so sagen?
Absolut.
Das ist immer noch ein Teil von mir.
Aber ich kann heute
gut damit umgehen.
Die schlimmste Frage war immer:
"Warum bist du nicht gegangen?"
Man kann den Mechanismus
nicht verstehen.
Wie diese Abhängigkeitsspirale
funktioniert.
Man braucht Hilfe von aussen.
Allein ist es machbar,
weil ich merkte,
dass mir das Wasser bis hier stand.
"Wenn ich jetzt nicht gehe,
bin ich tot."
Das spürten Sie?
- Ja.
"Egal wie."
"Entweder bringt er mich um
oder ich bringe mich um."
Wie sehen Sie das selber
mit etwas mehr Distanz:
Was haben Sie
aus dieser Zeit mitgenommen?
Ich kann verstehen,
dass gewisse Leute sagen,
ich sei nicht ganz dicht.
Ich war dort effektiv
nicht ganz dicht.
Ich hatte null Respekt
vor mir selber.
Aber jetzt habe ich gelernt
und muss noch lernen,
dass ich geliebt werden darf.
Und dass ich mich zuerst lieben
muss, bevor jemand mich lieben kann.
Ihr Sohn hat viel von dieser
häuslichen Gewalt miterlebt.- Ja.
Sprechen Sie manchmal miteinander
darüber, wie das für ihn war?
Ja. Es war schlimmer für ihn,
als ich dachte.
Schlimmer, als Sie dachten?
- Ja.
Ich würde jeder Frau mit Kindern,
die in dieser Situation ...
Jetzt werde ich traurig.
Mein Kind hat gelitten.- Mhm.
Mehr, als ich dachte.
Mhm.
Das werfe ich mir vor.
Ich wollte positiv sein,
aber wenn ich daran denke ...
Kinder kriegen alles mit. Alles.
Nicht nur ein bisschen.
Sie schlafen im Zimmer,
gehen aber auch schauen.
Sie wollen ja die Mutter beschützen.
Er hat alles mitgekriegt.
Abgesehen von
den ganz schlimmen Streitereien.
Da war er zum Glück nicht da.
Aber so hatte mein Mann
sozusagen Freigang:
Er konnte zuschlagen,
weil das Kind nicht da war.- Ja.
Aber alles andere kriegte er mit,
diese Demütigungen ...
Ich war natürlich ... Ich darf ...
Ich war auch hysterisch.
Ich sage nicht,
dass ich nett und brav war.
Ich war hysterisch am Boden.
Und er hat das gesehen.- Mhm.
Das tut mir heute wirklich megaleid.
Wenn man nicht gehen kann,
weil man in einer Abhängigkeit ist
und den Mann halt liebt ...
... sollte man
der Kinder wegen gehen.
Sie kriegen wirklich alles mit.
Eine solche Erfahrung wirkt sich
wahrscheinlich auf vieles aus.
Inzwischen ist Ihre Beziehung
nicht mehr neu,
aber in dem Film war sie noch neu.
Gibt es Momente,
in denen sich das überlagert?
Das ist schwierig. Eric und ich
kämpfen jetzt noch damit.
Wir sind beide sehr sensibel.
Da sind wir uns sehr ähnlich.
Das macht es nicht einfacher.
Am meisten muss ich
an meinem Vertrauen arbeiten.
Zu denken,
dass er es gut mit mir meint.
Warum denke ich: "Es ist komisch,
dass er mich liebt."
Haben Sie das Gefühl noch?
- Ja.
"Hm, der liebt mich?"
"Liebst du mich?"
Ich frage ihn zwölfmal pro Tag:
"Liebst du mich wirklich?"
Das nervt ihn so.
Irgendwann muss ich denken:
"Warum sollte er mich nicht lieben?"
Haben Sie sich schon gefragt,
warum es Sie getroffen hat?
Warum Sie diesen Mann hatten?
Ja, wahrscheinlich
wurde ich so erzogen.
Ich wurde von einem dominanten Mann,
Vater erzogen.
Er war nicht böse,
aber einfach dominant.
Die Frau war die Dienerin.
Ich wurde
in diese Rolle reinerzogen.
Dann kommt man schnell
wieder in diese Rolle rein.
Corinne T.,
was Sie uns erzählt haben,
passiert in der Schweiz sehr viel
häufiger, als man denken würde.
42 % der Frauen und 24 % der Männer
haben schon Gewalt in einer Beziehung
erlebt.
Häufig
ist das auch sexualisierte Gewalt.
Letztes Jahr wurden in der Schweiz
757 Vergewaltigungen angezeigt.
Man geht aber davon aus,
dass sehr viel mehr
tatsächlich passiert sind.
Die meisten Opfer
machen nie eine Anzeige.
U.a. darum,
weil sie sich vermutlich schämen
oder Angst davor haben,
man werfe ihnen vor,
sie hätten die Tat
irgendwie provoziert.
Genau das war ein Grund dafür,
dass wir vor zwei Jahren
einen Film über das Thema machten
und junge Frauen zeigten, die sagten,
es sei wichtig, öffentlich
über Vergewaltigungen zu sprechen.
Hallo zusammen.
Vielleicht erinnert ihr euch:
Letztes Jahr machte ich eine Story
zum Thema sexuelle Gewalt.
Ich erzählte, dass ich das
mit 13 auch erlebt hatte.
Ich war überwältigt
von den Rückmeldungen.
Ich entschied mich
letzten November dazu,
meine Geschichte auf Instagram
zu teilen - öffentlich für jeden.
Da ich in den letzten Jahren
oft damit konfrontiert wurde
und ich immer wieder spüre und höre,
dass Frauen solche Dinge erleben
und nicht den Mut haben,
darüber zu sprechen.
"Drei Tage vor Heiligabend
wurde ich vergewaltigt."
"Nicht von einem Fremden,
nicht auf dem Heimweg,
nicht in einer dunklen Gasse,
sondern in den vier Wänden
eines 'Freundes'."
Wir hatten auch schon bei ihm einen
Film geschaut, was kein Problem war.
Dann schauten wir diesen Film -
mit einem ziemlichen Abstand:
Ich sass ganz links, er ganz rechts.
Er fragte immer wieder, ob ich
nicht etwas näherkommen könne.
Ich sagte: "Nein,
für mich passt dieser Abstand."
Dann ...
Ja ...
Nach dem Film
fiel er ziemlich bald über mich her.
Ich hatte ihn plötzlich vor mir,
auf mir.
Dann ging es los.
Ich war sehr schockiert,
ich hatte das nicht erwartet.
Am Anfang versuchte ich,
ihn wegzustossen.
Ich versuchte, seinen Kopf
wegzustossen, dann seine Schultern.
Aber ich merkte schnell, dass ich
ihm komplett unterlegen war.
Bei mir war es so, dass mich
dieser Schulfreund verfolgte.
Er hielt mich
mit beiden Händen fest.
Ich versuchte mich zu wehren,
ich schrie.
Er meinte: "Hör doch einfach auf,
dann ist es schneller vorbei."
Nachdem ich mich so heftig gewehrt
und auch verletzt hatte,
an Scherben,
die auf dem Boden lagen,
entschied ich für mich:
Ich lasse es über mich ergehen.
Dann ist es schneller vorbei und ich
kann nach Hause, wo ich sicher bin -
zu meiner Mutter, zu meiner Familie.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Ich war damals 19 Jahre alt
und in einem Workcamp in Dänemark.
Und ...
Der Täter war einer aus der Gruppe,
mit dem ich mich sehr gut verstand
und zu dem ich Vertrauen hatte.
Er hatte irgendwann die Idee,
im Wald spazieren zu gehen.
Ich fand es cool,
mal von der Gruppe wegzugehen.
Ich hatte mir dabei
ehrlich nichts gedacht.
(Audioaufnahme)
Du hast einen Plan im Kopf.
Ich schaue mich um und sehe Bäume.
Blätter. Wald. Ich laufe locker.
Ich denke:
"Bald, bald küsst du mich."
"Vielleicht. Wer weiss? Oder wir
laufen nur im Wald im Kreis."
Und irgendwann blieb er stehen ...
... schaute mich an
und fragte mich auf Französisch ...
... ob ich ihm einen blasen will.
Ich war total überfordert
von der Frage,
weil ich die nicht kommen sah.
Er nahm dann
ziemlich schnell meinen Kopf ...
... und hielt mich fest,
während er mich penetrierte.
(Audio) Mund auf, Penis rein,
und ich schaue dir zu,
wie du von oben stehend
mich penetrierst,
wie du mehr und mehr
die Kontrolle verlierst.
Deine Hände sind fest um meinen
Kopf, meine Lippen um deinen ...
Es war für mich als die, die
das erlebt hat, total widerlich,
weil ich einen Würgereiz hatte
und kaum Luft bekam.
Und ...
Ich habe mich dann irgendwie
irgendwann von ihm weggezogen,
als er gekommen ist,
weil ich das total eklig fand.
Und ...
Ich war danach irgendwie
total überfordert mit der Situation.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Ich spürte weder Arme noch Beine,
nichts.
Ich hätte mich am liebsten
weiterhin gewehrt,
aber ich konnte
einfach nichts mehr spüren.
Ich konnte nichts mehr bewegen.
Dieses Gefühl ...
Ich hatte wirklich ein bisschen
das Gefühl, neben mir zu stehen.
Ich kriegte schon alles
sehr direkt mit, aber ...
Ich fühlte mich sehr machtlos.
Gut, da waren zum einen
die Hände um meinen Kopf, aber ...
Mein Körper hat einfach mitgemacht
und funktioniert.
Das ist wie eine Faust ins Gesicht,
wenn einem gesagt wird:
"Hey, du hast dich
einfach zu wenig gewehrt."
"Deshalb bist du selber schuld."
Das höre ich ständig.
Praktisch jeden Tag muss ich
unter meinen Beiträgen lesen,
ich sei selber schuld,
weil ich mich zu wenig lange
oder zu wenig heftig gewehrt habe.
Dazu muss ich einfach sagen: "Nein!"
Der Handlungsspielraum war da.
Das ist auch eines der Dinge,
die mich fertigmachen,
weil so vieles
hätte anders laufen können.
Ist es aber nicht.
Ich glaube, das ...
sehen viele Menschen sehr falsch.
"Hättest du dich gewehrt ..."
Es ist sehr einfach, das zu sagen,
wenn man es nicht erlebt hat.
Er hat mir viel genommen:
das Vertrauen zu anderen Menschen.
Ein Stück Freiheit.
Das ist für mich das Schlimmste,
weil das heute noch präsent ist.
Ich kann z.B.
keinen Aufzug benutzen.
Oder mit dem ÖV unterwegs zu sein,
bereitet mir extrem Bauchschmerzen.
Für mich war es einfach ein Witz,
was die Folgen für ihn waren.
Er musste zwölf Sozialstunden
absolvieren für das,
was er mit angetan hatte.
Das ist einfach nicht fair.
Es herrscht keine Gerechtigkeit.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Es war schon ziemlich heftig,
gewisse Reaktionen zu lesen.
Gewisse Kommentare
waren schon verletzend.
Ich hatte zwar damit gerechnet,
aber nicht in diesem Ausmass.
"Opfer?
Sie sind eine feige Lügnerin."
"Unglaubhafte Schlampen-Geschichte."
"Und wer sich so präsentieren muss -
wen wundert's?"
Morena Diaz, die wir im Film sahen,
sitzt jetzt auch auf dem Sofa.
Herzlich willkommen.
- Danke.
Ich fragte mich, ob der Schritt, die
Vergewaltigung öffentlich zu machen,
auch ein Teil des Prozesses ist,
um aus der "Opferrolle" zu kommen.
Absolut.
Ich schwieg
mehr oder weniger ein Jahr lang.
Das ist ja eine relativ kurze Zeit.
Andere schweigen mehrere Jahre.
Ich hatte aber einen grossen Drang,
etwas zu machen.
Ich merkte, dass es
so viel Ungerechtigkeit gibt,
dass es ein riesiges Tabuthema ist.
Ich habe eine grosse Plattform
und Reichweite
und wollte etwas Gutes tun.
Und mir nebenbei auch etwas Gutes.
Ich wollte darüber sprechen,
darüber schreiben -
einfach die Wut und den Frust
rauslassen.
Auf Social Media öffentlich zu werden
und etwas tun zu können -
ist das ein erster Schritt,
um sich nicht so hilflos zu fühlen?
Absolut.
Der Austausch tut einfach gut.
Die Dunkelziffer
ist nach wie vor riesig.
Bei den Anzeigen
und beim Darüber-Sprechen.
Bei der häuslichen Gewalt auch.
Geht es darum, nicht Opfer zu sein
oder dass das so krass ist,
dass man nicht darüber sprechen kann?
- Beides.
Einerseits wollen sich
die wenigsten eingestehen,
dass man Opfer von etwas
sehr, sehr Schlimmem wurde.
Man liest sonst
in den Zeitungen davon
und identifiziert sich nicht damit.
Das ging mir auch so.
Mein bester Freund verbalisierte,
was passiert war.
"Du wurdest vergewaltigt."
Und ich: "Sicher nicht.
Das war keine Vergewaltigung."
Laut Gesetz ist es ja
eine sexuelle Nötigung,
muss man fairerweise sagen.
In anderen Ländern
wäre es eine Vergewaltigung. Egal.
Wie benannten Sie das für sich?
Gar nicht.
Ich verdrängte das einfach.
"Es ist etwas Unangenehmes passiert,
that's it. Das Leben geht weiter."
Ich versuchte, das zu verdrängen.
Aber er sagte, ich solle die Augen
aufmachen, das sei eine Straftat.
Ich schämte mich auch dafür.
Dafür,
dass ich es "zugelassen" hatte.
Ich weiss,
dass es nicht meine Schuld ist.
Aber das hatte ich
noch nicht verstanden.
Welche Reaktionen gibt es,
wenn man wie Sie öffentlich
über Vergewaltigung spricht?
Leute, die sich für die Offenheit
und Ehrlichkeit bedanken.
Leute,
die sich damit identifizieren
und Halt, Mut und Zuversicht
in meinen Worten finden.
Und dann natürlich
das komplette Gegenteil.
Oft durfte ich hören,
ich sei eine Lügnerin.
Ich habe das alles erfunden,
um mehr Aufmerksamkeit
auf Social Media zu erhalten.
Und ich durfte lesen,
ich sei selber schuld daran.
Also, einerseits ist es nicht
passiert, andererseits aber schon,
aber ich bin schuld.
Egal, was man macht, es ist falsch.
Woher kommt das?
- Aus Aspekten der Misogynie,
also des Frauenhasses -
wir müssen uns eingestehen,
dass der immer noch in den Köpfen,
auch der Frauen, verankert ist.
Man glaubt Frauen
primär einfach nicht.
Das hat seine Wurzeln
in der Vergangenheit:
"Das sind Hexen,
sie lügen, sie erfinden Dinge."
Und das kommt von Männern, die auch
schon Grenzen überschritten haben.
Und vielleicht haben sie das
in dem Zug begriffen.
Ich sage nicht,
dass das alles Vergewaltiger sind,
aber Grenzen
sind schnell überschritten.
Ich kriegte auch viele
solche Kommentare von Frauen.
Ich denke, diese Leute
wollen sich selber schützen.
Also: "Sie hat sich
sicher falsch verhalten."
"Darum ist das passiert.
Das passiert mir nicht."
Welche Reaktionen
erhielten Sie nach diesem Film?
Mein Umfeld erschrak.
Sie hätten nicht gedacht,
dass es so schlimm war.
Sie hatten
diese Bilder noch nie gesehen.
Da hiess es: "Meine Güte ..." usw.
Aber es kam immer die Frage:
"Warum hat sie das mitgemacht?"
Das würde mir heute
nicht mehr passieren.
Es wird einem jeden Tag gesagt:
"Du bist schlecht. Du bist schuld."
Am Schluss entschuldigte ich mich
bei ihm für seine Taten.
"Es tut mir leid,
dass ich dich provoziert habe
und du mich schlagen musst."
Das ist Hirnwäsche.
Das ist eine Hirnwäsche.
Momentan
wird das Sexualstrafrecht revidiert.
Läuft aus Ihrer Sicht auch juristisch
etwas komplett falsch?- Definitiv.
Das Sexualstrafrecht fokussiert sich
auf das Verhalten des Opfers:
Hat das Opfer sich gewehrt?
Sagte es Nein?
Wie stark hat es sich gewehrt?
Wir wissen: Der Mensch reagiert
in Gefahrensituationen automatisch.
Es gibt fight, flight und freeze -
kämpfen, flüchten und einfrieren.
Dem Freeze-Element,
der Schockstarre,
wird zu wenig Beachtung geschenkt.
Genau das passierte bei mir: Mein
Körper fiel in eine Schockstarre.
Ich spürte meinen Körper nicht mehr.
Ich hätte mich wehren sollen:
Ich konnte nur Nein sagen.
"Nein" und "Bitte hör auf".
Aber das reichte nicht.
Das reicht laut Gesetz auch nicht.
Was braucht es, damit die Opfer
besser geschützt sind?
Wenn man Kinder und Jugendliche
heute fragt, ob es okay sei,
wenn jemand sie gegen ihren Willen
küsst oder berührt,
sagen alle Nein.
Warum ist das
nicht in der Gesetzgebung?
Die Gesetzgebung
hat eine Signalwirkung.
Mit der "Ja heisst Ja"-Lösung
gehen wir davon aus,
dass der Täter
eine Einwilligung geholt hat.
Und wenn er sie nicht geholt hat,
ist er strafbar.
Bei häuslicher Gewalt
oder Vergewaltigung
haben viele von uns -
da schliesse ich mich mit ein -
das Gefühl, das einem
das nicht passieren könnte.
Die Realität sieht häufig anders aus.
Was uns allen aber
definitiv passieren könnte,
das aber zum Glück wenigen passiert:
dass man das Zufallsopfer
einer Gewalttat wird.
Das ist Dominik Bein passiert.
Dominik Bein ging als 15-jähriger
Teenager in den Ausgang
und wurde brutal zusammengeschlagen.
* Düstere Klänge *
Es geschah am 26. April 2003
in Frauenfeld.
Sieben Neonazis waren angereist,
um "Linke zu vermöbeln".
Ausgestattet
mit Kampfstiefeln und Schlagringen.
Das eine Opfer: Reggae-Fan
Dominik Bein, 15 Jahre alt.
Dominik Bein überlebte
die Gewaltorgie nur ganz knapp.
Er trug
schwerste Hirnverletzungen davon
und ist seither körperlich
und kognitiv beeinträchtigt
und auf Betreuung angewiesen.
Einer der sieben Täter nahm sich
in der Untersuchungshaft das Leben.
Die anderen wurden zu fünf bis sechs-
einhalb Jahren Zuchthaus verurteilt.
Sie kamen ins Gefängnis,
sassen ihre Strafe ab,
kriegten einen Bewährungshelfer ...
Aber das Opfer kriegte nichts.
Niemand kam und sagte, sie würden
das eine oder andere übernehmen.
Oder ich müsse mir
keine Gedanken darüber machen
und solle mich um Dominik kümmern,
es werde mir geholfen.
Da kam niemand. Da half niemand.
Man muss selber schauen,
wie man weitermacht.
Das ist ungerecht.
Man denkt sich manchmal:
"Das ist ungerecht."
Ich gönne ihnen
den Bewährungshelfer,
und dass sie
auf dem rechten Weg sind.
Aber wenn sie schon
auf dem rechten Weg sind,
sollten sie
auch den Schaden bezahlen ...
... den sie verursacht haben.
Jetzt noch die andere Seite.
Jawohl. Schön
mit der linken Hand festhalten.
Du kannst das.
Rosmarie Bein ermöglicht ihrem Sohn
ein sehr selbstständiges Leben
in den eigenen vier Wänden,
indem sie ihr eigenes
vollständig auf Dominik ausrichtet.
Trotz alledem -
sie kann Dominik nicht alles geben,
was er sich wünscht.
Er merkt natürlich,
dass seine Freunde verheiratet sind
und Kinder haben.
Er merkt,
dass er immer an Grenzen stösst.
Das macht ihn fertig.
Damit kommt er fast nicht zurecht.
Er möchte auch eine Familie.
Er mag Kinder. Er möchte das auch.
Das macht mich immer sehr traurig.
Das ...
... ist ...
Mhm.
Genau.
Komm, Dominik,
wir rücken die Hose zurecht.
Sonst verlierst du sie
und du bist nackt im Fernsehen.
Nein.
Das ist nicht lustig, oder?
- Nein, nein.
Dann wärst du in der Unterhose.
- Nein.
Komm etwas näher.
So, jetzt kannst du vorne zumachen.
Dominik und seine Mutter
warten bis heute vergeblich
auf eine Entschuldigung der Täter.
Auch Schadenersatzzahlungen
sind bis jetzt ausgeblieben.
Ich weiss auch nicht,
ob das entschuldbar ist.
Ich denke,
das ist nicht entschuldbar.
Ich bete jeden Tag das Vaterunser.
Dort steht, dass man vergeben soll -
und das versuche ich.
Ich versuche es.
Aber in gewissen Situationen
kann ich das nicht.
In gewissen Situationen
kommt die Wut auf.
Was wäre, wenn?
Es ist schwierig für ihn.
Er wäre auch lieber gesund.
Aber es ist jetzt halt so.
Das Schicksal hat uns getroffen.
Wie würden Sie die Frage "Einmal
Opfer, immer Opfer?" beantworten?
Richtig. Das ist so.
Da gibt es nichts zu diskutieren.
Einmal Opfer, immer Opfer.
Nein.
Das Schicksal von Mutter und Sohn
Bein macht einen extrem betroffen.
Man hat wirklich den Eindruck,
als Opfer doppelt gestraft zu sein.
Ist das so
oder ist das eher die Ausnahme?
Die Opferhilfe ist eine der ersten
Anlaufstellen für Menschen,
die z.B. Gewalt erfahren haben.
Ich bin bei Thomas Gall
und Anja Heim,
die beide schon lange
in der Opferberatung arbeiten.
Sie haben tagtäglich
mit Menschen zu tun,
die Opfer
verschiedenster Umstände wurden.
Was ist das Erste,
das diese Leute von Ihnen wollen?
Was können Sie ihnen geben?
Die Leute kommen,
wenn sie an den Anschlag kommen.
Man merkt erst mit der Zeit,
was man alles tragen muss.
Welche Lasten auf einem liegen.
Gerade am Anfang
unterschätzt man völlig,
was man plötzlich an Rechnungen hat,
dass man sich mit Versicherungen
rumschlagen muss ...
Hat man ein Strafverfahren ein-
geleitet, muss man da Dinge tun ...
Wenn man schon
durch einen Vorfall verletzt wurde
und dann diesen Berg vor sich hat,
ist das doppelt frustrierend.
Der Fall,
den wir vorher gesehen haben -
diese unglaubliche Ungerechtigkeit.
Rosmarie Bein sagte:
"Uns hilft niemand."
Es ist so, dass das schweizerische
Strafverfolgungssystem
tatsächlich
mehr darauf ausgerichtet ist,
die Täter wieder zu reintegrieren.
Der Strafvollzug ist
eine finanziell teure Angelegenheit.
Man darf nicht vergessen,
dass gute Täterarbeit
auch Präventivarbeit ist.
Und die kann
potenziellen Opfern zugutekommen.
Aber wenn man selber Opfer wurde,
sieht man v.a. das Ungleichgewicht.
Das finde ich verständlich.
Hätte Dominik
einen Verkehrsunfall gehabt,
würden viele Versicherungen bezahlen.
Aber weil er
Opfer einer Gewalttat wurde,
steht er eigentlich allein da.
Wenn Sie
Opfer eines Verkehrsunfalls werden,
gibt es
eine Haftpflichtversicherung,
die für alle Schäden,
auch Folgeschäden, aufkommt.
Wenn Sie von einem Gewaltdelikt
geschädigt werden,
wird es arg schwierig.
Dann leistet
die eigene Unfallversicherung etwas.
Die versucht dann,
Regress zu nehmen.
Davon kriegen Sie nichts mit.
Aber Haftpflichtversicherungen
steigen bei Gewaltverbrechen aus.
Wir haben die Ungleichheit,
diese Ungerechtigkeit festgestellt.
Was müsste passieren, damit sich
die Situation derer verbessert,
die von Gewalt betroffen sind?
Man müsste sich überlegen,
was man noch mehr
zum Opferschutz machen kann.
Kann man z.B.
grundsätzlich einrichten,
dass es ab einer gewissen Schwere
einfach einen Opferanwalt
von Staates wegen gibt,
der die rechtliche Seite vertritt?
Kann man gewisse Versicherungs-
leistungen überdenken oder ausbauen?
Da gibt es viele Orte,
an denen man ansetzen könnte.
Wie gut ist die Lobby der "Opfer"
in der Politik?
Das Bewusstsein
ist in den letzten Jahren gestiegen.
Das ist immer wieder Thema.
Man weiss,
dass da nachgebessert werden kann.
Sie heissen Opferhilfe.
Wie gerne haben Sie das Wort Opfer?
In unserer täglichen Arbeit
vermeiden wir das Wort.
Das kommt eigentlich nicht vor.
Wenn ich nach aussen kommuniziere,
sind das geschädigte, gewalt-
betroffene Personen oder Betroffene.
Aber das Wort Opfer vermeiden wir
so gut es geht, weil es ...
... mittlerweile ein Stigma ist,
ein Schimpfwort.
Niemand ist gerne Opfer.
Wir sind auch nicht glücklich
über den Begriff.
Aber rechtlich
ist er immer noch sehr verankert.
Wenn Kinder sich auf dem Pausenplatz
"Du Opfer!" an den Kopf werfen,
meinen sie damit: "Du bist
ein Versager. Du bist ein Loser."
"Du bist ein komischer Typ."
Da passiert die Umkehrung:
Man gibt den Opfern das Gefühl,
man sei selber schuld.
"Du bist komisch.
Du hast die falschen Kleider."
"Du benimmst dich falsch."
Was es für junge Menschen bedeuten
kann, Opfer von Mobbing zu werden:
Wir haben jemanden getroffen,
der das erlebt hat.
Wenn Maik Bisquolm
in sein altes Schulhaus
im bündnerischen Rabius zurückkehrt,
fühlt er sich
sofort wieder so hilflos, unfrei
und voller Angst wie damals,
als er gemobbt wurde.
Das fing in der vierten Klasse an.
Und zwar
mit Sprüchen und Beleidigungen.
Gegen mich, gegen meine Familie.
Was war denn in den Augen der anderen
falsch an Ihnen?
Keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht meine Präsenz.
Dass ich da war.
Ich weiss es nicht.
Meine Familie hatte nicht viel Geld.
Ich wurde
von allen Gruppen ausgeschlossen.
Ich war viel allein.
Ich verbrachte die Pausen
oft allein.
Ich verzweifelte an mir selbst.
Ich musste zuschauen,
wie ich fertiggemacht wurde.
Das hatte auch Auswirkungen
auf die Schule und auf mich.
Auf die Hausaufgaben,
auf das Lernen ...
Ich mochte nicht mehr lernen, ich
mochte keine Hausaufgaben machen.
Ich machte nichts.
Ich stellte mich stur.
Ich war wie ein Stein.
Heute merke ich das leider.
Wenn ich einen Brief schreibe,
sind viele Rechtschreibfehler drin.
Ich merke,
dass ich nicht konzentriert war.
Ich war mit dem Kopf nicht dabei.
Seinen Eltern
vertraute Maik sich nicht an.
Diese hatten Ð so war er überzeugt Ð
selbst genug um die Ohren:
Der Vater mit Depressionen in
der Klinik, die Mutter am Arbeiten,
um die die vierköpfige Familie
allein durchzubringen.
Vom Mobbing erfuhr sie erst,
als Maik eine Woche lang nicht mehr
in der Schule erschienen war.
Es ist brutal ...
... wenn man darüber nachdenkt,
was alles passiert ist.
Und er hat keine Hilfe erhalten.
Das geht Ihnen wahrscheinlich
bis heute nach.- Ja, sicher.
Was tut Ihnen am meisten leid?
Dass wir ihm nicht helfen konnten.
- Mhm.
Dass viele Sachen ...
Dass solche Dinge manchmal ...
Wie sagt man? Man sieht das nicht.
Man kommt erst darauf, wenn ...
... die Situation
schon zu weit fortgeschritten ist.
Dass man anfangen muss ... Ja ...
Das waren auch ...
Das muss man sagen -
das waren auch harte Zeiten
für uns zwei.
Ein Gespräch mit Maiks Lehrer
brachte keine Besserung.
Sonja Bisquolm fackelte nicht lange:
Sie nahm ihren Sohn aus der Schule
und suchte eine neue für ihn.
Dort konnte er ein bisschen ...
Ein bisschen weg.
- Er konnte sich öffnen.
Er konnte sagen:
"Sie akzeptieren mich, wie ich bin."
Dort konnte er darüber sprechen.
Wir konnten
mit ihm darüber sprechen.
Er kam nach Hause und war fröhlich.
Er ging auf wie eine Blume.
- Ja.
Er drehte sich um 180°.
Wirklich.
Auch schulisch.
Er machte super Noten.
Er versuchte immer,
das Beste daraus zu machen.
Maik Bisquolm ist heute 24
und Fachmann Betriebsunterhalt.
Die Mobbingerfahrung und seine daraus
entstandene Verweigerungshaltung
wirkten sich
auf seine berufliche Zukunft aus.
Ich hätte gerne
Detailhandel gemacht.
Aber wegen der Rechtschreibung
ging das nicht.
Ich war dort schnuppern
und hätte sicher
irgendwann eine Stelle gekriegt ...
... aber mit der Rechtschreibung
usw. klappte es dann nicht.
Trotzdem:
Maik ist am Mobbing nicht zerbrochen.
Seiner ersten Liebe
gelang dies nicht.
Seine Freundin,
die ebenfalls gemobbt wurde,
nahm sich das Leben.
Ich war auch schon an diesem Punkt
in meinem Leben,
als ich mich fragte,
ob ich so weitermachen
oder doch nicht mehr dableiben will.
Wie schafften Sie es,
nicht zu verzweifeln?
Was hielt Sie am Leben? Warum
entschieden Sie sich gegen Suizid?
Bei mir war es diese innere Stimme.
Ich motivierte mich selbst.
Am Schluss sagte ich:
"Komm, du musst ...
... wieder nach oben kommen
und kämpfen."
Dann gab es immer mehr Faktoren.
Am Schluss
gab es eine gute Freundin,
die mich unterstützte.
Sie sagte: "Es gibt Dinge,
die du nicht ändern kannst."
"Aber du musst
das Beste daraus machen."
Und das machte ich.
Geht zu euren Eltern
oder zu Freunden.
Holt euch Hilfe. Erzählt davon.
Behaltet es nicht für euch selber.
Das ist sehr wichtig.
So eine Schulzeit
ist der absolute Horror für all jene,
die das selber erleben.
Aber auch
für die betroffenen Familien.
Damit so etwas weniger
oder bestenfalls nie mehr passiert,
sei das in den sozialen Medien
oder auf dem Pausenhof,
laufen verschiedene Anstrengungen:
(Frau) Was findet ihr
nicht so gut am Internet?
Ja.
- Man kann gemobbt werden.
Genau.
Mobbing - das ist das Thema.
Einerseits normales Mobbing,
aber auch im Internet.
Wie nennt man das?
Ja? Annika?
- Cybermobbing.
Genau.
Dann nennt man es Cybermobbing.
Das ist so,
als würdet ihr ein Plakat machen,
und darauf z.B. sagen ...
Wenn ihr mich beleidigen würdet:
"Caroline ist megablöd."
Ihr habt dann ein Foto von mir
und hängt das auf
und sagt das allen.
Man darf niemanden öffentlich
beleidigen, blossstellen,
runtermachen
oder schlechter behandeln.
Man kennt das klassische Mobbing:
Da wird z.B. jemand
auf dem Pausenplatz beleidigt
oder
von einer Aktivität ausgeschlossen.
Beim Cybermobbing
kommen noch drei Dinge dazu,
die es schwieriger machen:
erstens die Anonymität.
Es gibt Fälle, in denen Kinder
ein Fake-Profil anlegen,
z.B. auf Instagram,
Snapchat oder TikTok,
um jemanden fertigzumachen.
Weil man anonym bleiben kann,
ist die Hemmschwelle viel tiefer,
so etwas zu tun.
Das kann einfach so passieren
und hört nicht mehr auf.
Mobbing
ist eine grosse psychische Belastung
für Kinder und Jugendliche.
Wir sagen den Eltern immer,
man müsse hinhören,
wenn ein Kind sich viel zurückzieht
und sich nicht verabreden will.
Auch Bauch- oder Kopfschmerzen
oder v.a. im Jugendalter
bis hin zu einer Depression
oder selbstverletzendem Verhalten
können darauf hindeuten.
Mobbing nimmt einem
gerade in dem Alter viel weg.
Man will sich ja mit anderen treffen
und eine Identität bilden,
indem man sich
mit Gleichaltrigen austauscht.
Wenn man immer ausgeschlossen wird,
kann das zu viel Schmerz führen.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Der Fall Céline erschütterte
vor fünf Jahren die Schweiz.
Die 13-jährige Schülerin
aus Spreitenbach nahm sich das Leben,
nachdem sie
in den sozialen Medien gemobbt
und mit erpressten, freizügigen Fotos
blossgestellt worden war.
(Frau) Schlimme Fälle mit Suizid
hatten wir nicht.
Wir hatten aber
beginnende Situationen.
Da meldeten sich Eltern bei mir.
Ich reagierte darauf,
wir gingen ins Gespräch
und sammelten Beweismittel.
Und wir führten Gespräche
mit den betroffenen Eltern
und auch mit den Opfern und Tätern.
Es war interessant:
Meistens löste sich das dann auf.
Die Eltern von Kindern,
die so etwas machen,
sind meistens
sehr schnell sehr betroffen darüber,
dass ihr Kind das macht,
weil sie das nicht wussten.
Sie schauen dann genauer hin
und reagieren.
So kann man das auflösen.
Wir von Pro Juventute
empfehlen nicht,
dass Eltern die anderen Eltern
direkt kontaktieren.
Man sollte das Element Schule
unbedingt mit reinnehmen.
Auch wenn sich das sehr
ins Cybermobbing verlagert,
braucht es den sozialen
Anknüpfungspunkt der Schule.
Oder von Sportvereinen oder Orten,
an denen man sich trifft.
Als die Schulen während der Pandemie
geschlossen waren,
hatten wir viel weniger Anfragen
zu Cybermobbing.
In der Zeit fiel die Bühne wie weg.
Wichtig ist,
dass man Beweismaterial sichert.
Man kann z.B. Screenshots machen.
Man kann auch eine Anzeige machen,
wenn es in eine Richtung geht,
bei der man eine Strafverfolgung
in Gang setzten will.
Das kann man
von Fall zu Fall entscheiden.
Wichtig ist,
das nicht allein zu machen,
sondern Fachstellen mit ihrem
Erfahrungsschatz miteinzubeziehen.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Gehört es
einfach zum Menschsein dazu,
dass es Täter gibt
und entsprechend auch Opfer?
Die Frage geht an Yves Bosshart,
der mit mir auf dem Sofa sitzt.
Er ist Philosoph und Moderator
von "Sternstunde Philosophie".
Ist das gar nicht anders vorstellbar?
Ich denke, es gehört dazu,
dass wir uns gegenseitig verletzen
und wir verletzliche Wesen sind.
Dass nicht alles mit rechten und
gerechten Dingen zu- und hergeht,
gehört dazu. Damit müssen wir leben.
Haben sich die alten Philosophen
mit Opfern beschäftigt?
Sie beschäftigten sich
natürlich auch mit Ungerechtigkeit
und mit Formen der Diskriminierung
und Ungleichbehandlung.
Mobbing gibt es
seit dem Anfang der Menschheit.
Dass man gehänselt wird, Leute auf
ihre Äusserlichkeiten reduzierte ...
Dass man sie entwürdigte ...
Das gibt es schon immer.
Wir sind heute einfach sehr sensibel
auf jegliche Diskriminierungsformen.
Von handfester Diskriminierung
und Ungleichbehandlung -
kriegt jemand denselben Lohn
für dieselbe Arbeit -
aber auch auf subtile Formen
der Ungleichbehandlung.
Wenn z.B. jemand im Tram
so mit breiten Beinen dasitzt
oder einem immer dreingeredet wird.
Wir sehen, dass wir ein Sensorium
dafür entwickelt haben.
Ich finde es richtig und wichtig,
dass wir auch ein Gespür für subtile
Formen der Herabwürdigung haben.
Und auch den Mut haben,
das zu artikulieren.
Es gibt auch
die Generation Snowflake.
Also,
dass alle ein bisschen Mimosen sind.
Schneeflöckchen, die ...
... schnell zerfallen,
wenn man sie anfasst.
Das ist etwas despektierlich.
- Das ist es, genau.
Ich glaube,
das trifft trotzdem einen Punkt.
Aber ich würde das
nicht negativ werten.
Die Sensibilität hat zugenommen.
Für Verletzungen aller Art und für
subtile Formen von Diskriminierung.
Grundsätzlich
ist das aber etwas Gutes.
Es gibt natürlich die Umkehrung.
Es werden langsam
immer mehr Stimmen gehört
und erhalten Präsenz
und Sichtbarkeit,
die marginalisiert, diskriminiert
und an den Rand gedrängt sind.
Seien das Schwarze, Frauen,
Personen, die korpulenter sind ...
Das Stichwort Diversität ist
natürlich auch wichtig. Vielfalt.
Und dass alle dasselbe Recht haben,
gehört zu werden.
Dass alle
auf der gleichen Augenhöhe sind,
ist eigentlich etwas Gutes.
Aber das hat damit zu tun,
dass gewisse Leute -
man sagt oft "alte, weisse Männer" -
Privilegien verlieren,
die sie jahrzehnte-
oder jahrhundertelang hatten.
Da findet natürlich
ein Machtkampf statt.
Haben wir manchmal auch gesell-
schaftlich etwas Mühe mit Menschen,
die sich als Opfer bezeichnen,
weil Menschen auch Opfer
von uns als Gesellschaft werden?
Weil wir als Gesellschaft
natürlich auch Dinge machen,
die für uns okay sind,
aber für andere weniger?- Genau.
Es ist immer auch
ein Vorwurf an uns selber,
an die Gesellschaft
und die Spielregeln.
Wir kennen den strukturellen
Rassismus, Sexismus -
in unserem Code,
wie wir miteinander umgehen,
sind schon viele Vorurteile
und Abwertungen drin.
Das merken wir gar nicht,
weil es so alltäglich ist.
Weil wir jahrzehntelang so lebten.
Und jetzt sagt jemand:
"Das ist ungerecht. Das geht nicht."
Jetzt müssen wir uns
in die andere Perspektive versetzen
und zuhören, wie sie die Welt sehen.
Das ist etwas Gutes,
aber für viele ist das irritierend.
Bleiben wir beim Cybermobbing:
Eine Frage ist auch,
was uns dazu bringt,
andere Leute zu belästigen
und zu beschimpfen.
Woher kommt das?
Das hat viel
mit der Anonymität zu tun.
Weil man kann.
- Man muss sich nicht anschauen.
So kann man einfach
den eigenen Selbstwert steigern.
Man fühlt sich besser,
indem man andere runtermacht.
Oder man kann einfach seinen Hass
oder seine Wut rauslassen.
Man kriegt zu wenig Anerkennung,
hat einen Minderwertigkeitskomplex -
da kann man sich aufblasen und gegen
andere lästern und Hass verbreiten.
Wir selber leiden ja nicht darunter.
Was kommt zurück?
Man kann sich verstecken.
Aber die andere Person
kriegt diesen sog. Shitstorm ab
und das macht natürlich
etwas mit ihnen.
Menschen, die Schlimmes
erfahren haben, leiden darunter.
Zusätzlich
leiden aber viele noch darunter,
dass man ihnen nicht glauben will
oder nicht hören will,
dass sie Opfer wurden.
Wie z.B. Walter Nowak.
In dieser vermeintlichen Idylle,
in Zollikofen bei Bern,
hat alles angefangen Ð
und zwar denkbar schlecht.
Walter Nowak kehrt nach fast 40
Jahren zum ersten Mal dorthin zurück,
wo sein Unglück
seinen Lauf genommen hat.
Es ist irgendwie schon seltsam.
Freute sich Ihre Mutter,
als sie Sie bekam?
Wie ich hörte, nicht, nein.
- Warum denn nicht?
Weil mein Vater ja angeblich sagte:
"Wenn es ein Junge ist,
verlasse ich dich, ist es
ein Mädchen, bleibe ich bei dir."
Dann hatten Sie leider
das falsche Geschlecht.
Ja, leider. Das musste ich
auch immer und immer wieder hören.
Ja.
Dass ich quasi schuld bin,
dass ihre Ehe zu Bruch ging.
Mittlerweile weiss ich,
dass das nicht stimmt.
Sie waren einfach
zu unterschiedlich.
Mein Vater war Antialkoholiker.
Er war ein Karrieremensch.
Meine Mutter hingegen
war schwer alkoholabhängig
und ihm deshalb mehr oder weniger
ein Klotz am Bein.
Aber es ist natürlich einfacher,
einem Kind die Schuld zu geben,
anstatt sich selbst.
Wie liess Ihre Mutter Sie das spüren?
Ja, durch fehlende ... Liebe.
Von Liebe kann man gar nicht reden.
Ich bekam
nie eine Umarmung, einen Kuss ...
... oder einen Schmatzer
von meiner Mutter.
Ich war eigentlich
immer der Sündenbock für alles,
was in der Wohnung
war oder passierte.
Ich war immer
für alles verantwortlich.
Nowak auf seinem alten Fluchtweg
Richtung Aare.
Seine Mutter hatte bald
einen neuen Mann gefunden -
einen, der besser zu ihr passte:
einen Alkoholiker.
So wurde es zu Hause
noch unerträglicher.
Hier war es einfach ruhig.
Ich liess hier jeweils
meine Seele baumeln.
Und spielte mit meinem Hund.
Der mochte Sie?
- Ja, das war eigentlich ...
... meine Bezugsperson,
wenn man so will.
Der Hund?
- Ja, der Hund.
Und meine Grossmutter -
so gut sie konnte.
Meine Grossmutter
beschützte mich, so gut sie konnte.
Als sie dann nicht mehr da war,
prasselte die ganze Aggression,
die meine Mutter in sich hatte,
auf mich hinab.
In welcher Form?
- In Form von Schlägen.
Ich erinnere mich noch,
als ich mal nach Hause kam,
nachdem ich im Kies gestürzt war
und mir die Hände aufgerissen hatte.
Ich kam heim,
wollte nur in die Badewanne,
weil es so brannte und um den Kies
aus den Wunden zu kriegen.
Ich vergass dabei,
dem Hund die Pfoten zu putzen.
Dann kam er rein,
als ich in der Badewanne sass,
und schlug mich in der Badewanne
mit dem Karabiner blutig.
Er schlug nur noch, ohne zu schauen.
Fast 30 Jahre hatte Nowak seine
Erinnerungen erfolgreich verdrängt -
doch mit Anfang 50
holten sie ihn ein.
Es waren eine Art Flashbacks.
Erinnerungsstücke,
die kamen und dann blieben.
Sie gaben mir
eigentlich die Gewissheit,
dass ich da
meine verlorene Kindheit nachträume.
Diese Erinnerungen kommen jetzt
langsam wieder an die Oberfläche.
Nowak begann,
sich an die Ostschweiz zu erinnern -
daran,
dass es zu Hause nicht mehr ging.
Dass er darum mit 13
ins Kloster Fischingen im Kanton
Thurgau gekommen war.
Und daran,
dass er, den keiner wollte,
das ideale Opfer gewesen und dort
jahrelang missbraucht worden war.
Nowak fasste den Mut
zu einer Anzeige -
und 2012
zum Gang an die Öffentlichkeit.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Immer mehr ehemalige Zöglinge
melden sich
und bestätigen Nowaks Vorwürfe:
Auch sie hätten in Fischingen
alles andere als Nächstenliebe
und Barmherzigkeit erfahren.
Es war erschütternd.
Wir alle ahnten, dass nicht alles
mit rechten Dingen zu- und herging.
Wenn man es aber
schwarz auf weiss sieht,
ist es sehr berührend
und erschütternd.
Das systematische Versagen der
Aufsicht und die fehlende Kontrolle
sind nun offiziell.
Zu einem Prozess kommt es
wegen der Verjährung indes nicht.
Für die Gewaltexzesse
und sexuellen Übergriffe
wird niemand je
die Verantwortung übernehmen.
Kein Seelenmord wird je gesühnt.
Der psychische Missbrauch
ist eigentlich am schlimmsten.
Sie nahmen vielen von uns
die Chance auf ein normales Leben.
Und auf ein erfolgreiches Leben.
Auf ein Leben,
bei dem man ein gewisses
Selbstwertgefühl mitnimmt ...
... um das Leben überhaupt zu
geniessen und etwas zu erreichen.
1970 wurde Nowak
nach Münsterlingen gebracht:
in die psychiatrische Klinik.
Da war er 14.
Im Kloster war aufgefallen,
dass seine Schulleistungen
stark nachgelassen hatten.
Heute ist klar:
eine Folge des Missbrauchs.
"Es ist natürlich möglich,
dass unerfreuliche Erlebnisse
diese depressive Störung
ausgelöst haben",
wurde in Münsterlingen festgehalten.
Diesen "unerfreulichen Erlebnissen"
ging jedoch niemand nach.
Vielmehr trieb das Schicksal Nowak
ins nächste Unglück -
in Form von Medikamentenversuchen.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Roland Kuhn,
der damalige Klinikdirektor,
testete zu jener Zeit Medikamente
am lebenden Objekt - auch an Kindern.
An Kindern wie Walter Nowak.
Dass einige dieser Medikamente
noch nicht mal einen Namen hatten
und Kuhn sie in ständig
ändernder Kombination verabreichte,
ist kein Zufall.
Nowak
war eines seiner Versuchskaninchen.
Mittlerweile ist belegt,
dass Kuhn mit Pharmafirmen
wie Geigy und Ciba-Geigy
zusammenarbeitete - später
aufgegangen in der heutigen Novartis.
Nowak leidet heute
unter einem viel zu hohen Blutdruck.
In den Akten taucht zwei Jahre nach
dem Beginn der Medikamentenversuche -
da ist er 16 - erstmals
ein entsprechender Hinweis auf.
Und nun quälen ihn
seit Monaten Bauchschmerzen.
Er hat Blut im Stuhl.
Man rechnet mit dem Schlimmsten.
Ich glaube, jedem
ist sein Lebensweg vorgeschrieben.
Wenn er zu Ende ist, ist er zu Ende.
Ich glaube, dass ...
... der Tod eine Erlösung sein kann.
Dass man dann in eine bessere
und andere Welt kommt.
Auf irgendeine Art und Weise.
Doch Nowaks Zeit
scheint noch nicht abgelaufen.
Die Untersuchungen
verlaufen ohne Ergebnis.
Ich bin zurück
bei der Opferhilfe beider Basel.
Menschen wie Walter Nowak
können sich auch hier melden.
Menschen, die von fürsorgerischen
Zwangsmassnahmen betroffen sind,
wie z.B. Heimplatzierungen,
Verdingkinder,
Menschen, die zu Sterilisationen
oder Abtreibungen gezwungen wurden.
Da gibt es eine sehr unrühmliche
Palette an Dingen,
die bis in die 80er-Jahre
des letzten Jahrhunderts passierten.
Sind all diese Fälle
so verschachtelt und komplex,
dass man das Gefühl hat,
wer einmal Pech hatte,
hat ein zweites und drittes Mal Pech?
Die Geschichte von Walter Nowak
hören wir wirklich oft.
Aber natürlich
ist es nicht immer so,
dass wieder und wieder
etwas passiert.
Das ist nicht immer so.
Aber was ihm in Fischingen
und auch danach passiert ist,
sind tatsächlich ...
... leider die Regelfälle
in dem Zusammenhang.
Wie können Sie jemandem
mit einer solchen Geschichte helfen?
Die Erfahrung hat gezeigt, dass es
extrem wichtig und wertvoll ist,
dass man diesen Personen
überhaupt mal zuhört.
Dass sie endlich einen Ort haben,
wo sie gehört werden,
wo man ihnen glaubt und hilft,
das Gesuch zu stellen,
Akten zu suchen usw.
Wenn sie das therapeutisch
noch nicht aufgearbeitet haben,
kriegen sie Hilfe,
um einen Therapieplatz zu finden.
Sie sind sehr dankbar,
dass sie endlich einen Ort haben,
an den sie hingehen können
und sich nicht mehr schämen müssen.
Wir sind quasi
wie das Ohr des Staates.
Der Staat hört hier
zum ersten Mal richtig zu.
Oft hat das diesen Aspekt.
Vielleicht haben sie es
in der Familie schon erzählt.
Ich lernte viele Leute kennen,
bei denen die engste Familie
nichts über die Kindheit wusste.
Oder nur ganz rudimentär.
Das hat eine Bedeutung
für die Leute.
Sie kriegen hier vom Staat
quasi eine definierte Stelle,
wo sie hinkommen können
und wo ihnen jemand zuhören muss
und das auch macht.
Kann der Solidaritätsbeitrag,
den die Menschen zugute haben,
dieses Unrecht, das passiert ist,
wieder "gutmachen"?
Ganz klar: nein.
Es geht nicht um Wiedergutmachung.
Es geht darum, das Unrecht,
das der Staat damals vollzogen hat,
endlich anzuerkennen
und sich zu entschuldigen.
Es gibt keine Betragshöhe, die eine
gestohlene Kindheit wiedergutmacht.
Die ist weg.
Die kann man nicht mehr erleben.
Die Geschichte der Kindheit
nimmt man ein Leben lang mit.
Die ist da.
Das kann man nicht gutmachen.
Wenn man Gewalt erlebt hat
und zum Opfer wurde,
ist das für die Betroffenen
ein grosser Einschnitt im Leben.
Z.T.
tragen sie auch ein Trauma davon.
Ich frage mich,
wie man über sowas hinwegkommt.
Diese Frage führt mich in die Praxis
der Psychiaterin Rosilla Bachmann.
Was wollen die Leute von Ihnen?
Was ist ihr Ziel?
Es kann sein, dass die Leute
sehr lange mit niemandem
darüber gesprochen haben.
Und plötzlich
halten sie es nicht mehr aus.
Oder es ist Zeit: "Mein Vater, der
mich missbrauchte, ist gestorben."
"Ich bin in der Scheidung."
"Die Kinder sind ausgeflogen."
Sie merken, dass sie
die Erinnerung an dieses Trauma
nicht mehr verdrängen wollen -
das braucht viel Energie -
oder können.
Es gibt aber auch Leute, die ...
... traumatisiert wurden
und z.B. depressiv werden
oder starke Ängste entwickeln
und dann deswegen kommen.
Also wegen etwas anderem.
- Weiter oben an der Oberfläche.
Im Verlauf der Behandlung sagen sie:
"Das ist mir passiert."
Walter Nowak
verdrängte das sehr lange.- Genau.
In Träumen merkte er plötzlich,
dass etwas passiert war.
Es gibt ja Traumafolgestörungen.
Man kann eine Depression entwickeln,
Angststörungen,
eine posttraumatische
Belastungsstörung ...
Das bedeutet, dass die Verdrängung
dort nicht so lückenlos ist.
Die Erinnerungen an das Trauma,
die z.T.
sehr körperlich abgespeichert sind,
kommen - wir sind auf der Zeitachse
hier in der Gegenwart -
und stülpen sich sozusagen
über die Gegenwart.
Man hat die Bilder, Gefühle
und Körpergefühle dieser Situation
und ist wie ausgeliefert.
Man fühlt sich
gleich ohnmächtig wie dazumal.
Das beschreibt Walter Nowak.
Er konnte das nicht mehr verdrängen.
Das Verdrängen
ist eine Überlebensstrategie.
Ist das immer schlecht?
- Nein, nicht nur.
Es ist da nicht anders möglich.
Muss man immer darüber sprechen
und eine Therapie machen?
Kann verdrängen eine Strategie sein?
- Das kann eine sein.
Walter Nowak
war ja als Kind und als Jugendlicher
immer wieder
diesen Traumata ausgesetzt.
Das ist einfach
eine Überlebensstrategie,
weil man anders nicht im Alltag
funktionieren könnte.
Es ist auch das Recht
jedes Betroffenen zu entscheiden ...
... ob man
die Büchse der Pandora öffnet.
Wenn man darüber spricht,
konfrontiert man sich
mit den Erfahrungen.
Da muss man
brutale Gefühle aushalten.
Dafür muss man gewappnet sein.
Darum brauchen gewisse Leute
vielleicht Jahrzehnte ...
... um die Kraft dafür zu sammeln.
Das ist harte Arbeit.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
In einer anderen Sendung
beschäftigten wir uns mit den Tätern.
Wir fragten, ob sie sich mit
ihren Opfern beschäftigen müssen.
Ist es für ein Opfer wichtig,
um darüber hinwegzukommen,
dass man dem Täter vergibt?
Wenn ich das höre und mir vorstelle,
wer meine Patienten sind ...
... steht die Vergebung
in der Behandlung nicht zuoberst.
In der Behandlung gibt es
manchmal wie einen heiligen Zorn.
Und das ist das Gegenteil
von Vergebung und Verzeihung.
Die Betroffenen sagen:
"Ich finde es so ungerecht,
dass mir das passiert ist."
"Das ist so gemein.
Das hat mir so geschadet."
Das ist auch eine Treibfeder,
um sich
wieder auf die Beine zu stellen
und sich
mit der Situation zu konfrontieren.
Und sich auszurichten: "Wo bin ich?
Was kann ich jetzt machen?"
Da finde ich die Wut die gesündere
Reaktion in der Behandlung.
Die ist für mich fast wichtiger.
Was braucht es,
um aus dem "Opfersein" rauszukommen?
Es braucht wirklich einen Plan.
Und wenn der Plan nur ist:
"Ich brauche Hilfe."
Vielleicht gibt auch Bezugspersonen
im Umfeld, die sagen:
"Hey, dir geht es nicht gut.
Such dir Hilfe!"
"Schau dir an, was mit dir los ist."
Es gibt ja Resilienzfaktoren.
Resilienz ist eine Art Anpassungs-
oder Widerstandsfähigkeit.
Das ist ein Elastizitätsbegriff.
Quasi: Es kommt ein Trauma.
Im besten Fall
gibt es eine Elastizität
und man findet
wieder zurück in den alten Zustand.
Man nimmt keinen Schaden,
hat keine Wunden.
Es gibt Faktoren,
die einem dabei helfen:
stabile Bezugspersonen, gute soziale
Beziehungen und Bindungen,
dass man sich aufgehoben fühlt,
dass man lernt, in schwierigen
Phasen eine Sinnhaftigkeit zu sehen.
Dass man lernt,
Ungewissheit auszuhalten -
also auch
eine Frustrationstoleranz hat.
Da kommt viel rein,
das man sich im besten Fall
in der normalen Entwicklung,
als Kind aneignen darf.
Muss man Resilienz einfach haben
oder kann man das lernen?
Man kann das lernen.
Z.T. wurde einem das genommen,
aber man kann es lernen.
Das ist die gute Nachricht.
- Dafür ist die Therapie da.
Man sagt immer,
man müsse darüber hinwegkommen.
Geht das überhaupt?
Es geht darum, dass man es dort
ablegen kann, wo es hingehört:
in die Vergangenheit.
Dass es sich nicht immer aktiviert
und einen in der Gegenwart stört.
Das ist im besten Fall
dieses "Abschliessen".
Mal schauen, ob Walter Nowak
Zeit für uns hat in Wien.
Hallo.
- Hallo, Herr Nowak.
Ich muss den Kopf richtig haben.
- Genau.
Das sieht richtig idyllisch aus.
Wo sind Sie?
Irgendwo in Wien.
- Irrsinnig.
Walter Nowak, Sie haben Good News.
Sie haben einen
sehr wichtigen Teilsieg errungen
in Ihrem Kampf um Gerechtigkeit:
Das Thurgauer Obergericht
hat kürzlich entschieden,
dass Ihr Fall,
obwohl es schon 40 Jahre her ist,
nicht verjährt ist.
Ja, es ging mir nie um Geld.
Es geht mir um Gerechtigkeit.
Und das ist ein Teilsieg
auf dem Weg zur Gerechtigkeit.
Ich bin froh,
dass ich das erreicht habe.
Ich hoffe, dass es für andere,
die auch so Schlimmes erlebt haben,
einfacher wird.
Man darf sie nicht vergessen.
Wir leiden heute noch darunter.
Sie haben gesagt,
es sei ein Teilsieg.
Sie sind noch nicht am Ziel.
Nein. Ich möchte schon noch ...
Ich habe Novartis
sehr viele Fragen gestellt,
die sie nie beantwortet haben.
Auch die Kirche
hat meine Fragen nicht beantwortet.
Eine Schuldanerkennung
oder was auch immer das ist,
ist sicher schön,
aber ich möchte auch wissen,
was genau passiert ist.
Ich weiss das immer noch nicht.
Wieso hat man uns so behandelt?
Wieso haben wir das alles verdient?
Das ist einfach unmenschlich.
Ich werde immer
gegen Unmenschlichkeit kämpfen.
Es ist mir egal, um was es geht.
Es ist unglaublich,
was Sie alles erlebt haben.
Wenn ich Sie aber so sehe,
habe ich das Gefühl,
Sie sind irgendwie angekommen
und haben ein gutes Leben.
Ich hörte vor zwei Jahren
mit der Öffentlichkeitsarbeit auf.
Und mit meinem Fall abgeschlossen
habe ich schon vorher. Musste ich.
Ich habe zehn Jahre verschwendet,
weil ich dachte,
ich erreiche nichts
mit dieser Aufklärung.
Wie lange will ich meine Kindheit
im Vordergrund belassen?
Ich habe sie ja schon mal erlebt.
Und jetzt noch mal. Das reicht.
Ich habe damit abgeschlossen.
Ich ziehe das natürlich durch,
aber ich mache das
mit einer gewissen Distanz,
damit es mir
nicht mehr so schaden kann.
Es ist schön zu sehen, dass Sie
an einem Ort angekommen sind,
wo es Ihnen
den Umständen entsprechend gut geht.
Das gebe ich
allen mit auf ihren Weg:
Es gibt viele Momente,
in denen die Sonne nicht scheint,
aber irgendwann scheint sie wieder.
Vielen Dank, Walter Nowak.
- Gerne.
Alles Gute. Danke vielmals.
- Danke.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Ich bin zurück auf dem Sofa
mit Yves Bossart.
Wenn man Walter Nowak sieht,
der Unglaubliches erlebt hat,
fragt man sich schon, wie man als
Mensch damit leben oder umgehen kann,
wenn man
so viel Ungerechtigkeit erlebt hat.
Sagt die Philosophie etwas dazu?
Die Philosophie sagt zu allem etwas.
Ob es brauchbar ist ...
Viele wissen nicht, dass dieser
berühmte Satz von Nietzsche stammt:
"Was mich nicht umbringt,
das macht mich stärker."
Wenn man auf sein eigenes Leben,
eine Beziehung, Krisenmomente
und schwere Zeiten zurückschaut ...
Oft wächst man ja daran.
Ausser es ist eine krasses Trauma,
an dem man zerbricht.
Aber in der Regel sind das Momente,
in denen man
gegen Widerstände kämpft.
Und die machen uns
auch zu anderen Menschen.
Wenn wir nur in der Komfortzone
und in der heilen Welt sind,
haben wir keine Reibung, keinen
Anstoss von aussen, zu wachsen.
Nietzsche sagt sogar,
Glück sei eine Form von ...
Ein Gefühl, einen inneren Widerstand
überwunden zu haben.
Diese Gefühl von wachsen,
von lebendig
und auch wandelbar zu sein.
Ich bin
auf keine Rolle festgeschrieben.
Ich kann daran arbeiten
und mich verändern.
Das gibt vielen Leuten
auch Kraft und Hoffnung.
Das wäre die positive Interpretation.
- Ja.
Aber wenn man ein Schicksal
wie Walter Nowaks sieht,
kann das sehr zynisch sein:
"Egal, was dir passiert: Sei dankbar,
vielleicht ist es für etwas gut."
Genau.
Das ist auch die gefährliche Seite.
Das Gegenbild heisst ja, dass wir
nicht einfach isolierte Wesen sind.
Wir sind soziale Wesen,
Beziehungswesen.
Der jüdische Philosoph Martin Buber
sagte schön:
"Der Mensch wird am Du zum Ich."
Die anderen machen und prägen
mein Selbstbild, meinen Selbstwert.
Gerade, was in der Kindheit
und Pubertät passiert,
wenn unsere Persönlichkeit
geformt wird -
da sind andere Vorbilder so prägend,
egal ob Freunde, Eltern oder Lehrer.
Sich danach,
wenn man Schlimmes erlebt hat,
den eigenen Selbstwert
und das Bild davon, wer man ist,
ganz unabhängig von der Erwartung
anderer aufzubauen,
ist unendlich schwierig.
Das zeigt so ein Fall.
Nach so etwas zu einer inneren
Stärke und Festigkeit zu finden,
ist fast unmöglich.
Das Stichwort Selbstliebe, Selbstwert
haben wir ein paarmal gehört.
Kommt das auch aus der Philosophie?
Ja ...
Bei Seneca in der antiken,
römischen Philosophie,
bei den Stoikern - wir kennen ja
die stoische Gelassenheit ...
Er prägte den Begriff
einer Freundschaft mit sich selber.
Das finde ich schöner
als die Liebe zu sich selber.
Das klingt sonst so egozentrisch
oder narzisstisch.
Bei der Freundschaft mit sich selber
überlegt man,
was man mit guten Freunden macht.
Man verbringt Zeit zusammen,
man ist offen und ehrlich,
man ist aber auch wohlwollend,
geht zusammen spazieren ...
Jetzt muss man das
auch mit sich selber machen.
Ich verbringe Zeit mit mir selber,
spreche offen und ehrlich,
spreche Dinge an, bin aber wohl-
wollend und kritisiere nicht alles.
Oft sind wir selber
unsere schlimmsten Kritiker.
Die Idee der Selbstfreundschaft
half mir viel.
Das wollte ich fragen: Kannst du das?
Ja. Wie alles im Leben
ist das Übungssache.
Aber ich glaube, letztlich kann man
nur glücklich und zufrieden sein,
wenn man ein gesundes,
freundschaftliches Verhältnis
zu sich selber aufbauen kann.
Ein letztes Mal
zurück zu Walter Nowak nach Wien.
Zwölf Jahre lang war er beschäftigt
mit
der Bewältigung seiner Geschichte.
Für eine Beziehung
blieb keine Energie.
Und jetzt hat ihn die Liebe
doch noch gefunden,
in der Person von Nadja Hummel.
Kann die Liebe seine Wunden heilen?
Ich denke,
sie kann das einfacher machen.
Heilen weiss ich nicht.
Ich glaube nicht.
Das ist schon ziemlich ...
Gut, ich habe damit abgeschlossen.
Ich leide nicht mehr.
Ich sehe mich nicht mehr als Opfer.
Ich bin höchsten betroffen.
Ich habe gelernt:
einmal Opfer, immer Opfer.
Das stimmt. Ich kenne solche Leute,
die leider immer noch Opfer sind.
Sie kommen nicht da raus.
Ich glaube, da habe ich
genug lange an mir gearbeitet,
um den Schritt zu schaffen.
Es gibt immer wieder Situationen,
in denen Walo getriggert wird.
Das ist ihm bewusst.
Und mir auch. Wir gehen damit um.
So wie ich
auch meinen Rucksack habe.
Jeder Mensch.
In unserem Alter sowieso.
Ja. Es ist mir lieber ...
... wenn einem bewusst ist,
welche Geschichte man hat,
und man an sich arbeitet.
Dass man reflektieren kann.
Das ist bei ihm gegeben
und das ist viel wert.
Ja.
Er ist ein sehr besonderer Mensch.
Ich glaubte nicht mehr daran,
dass man mich lieben kann.
Das war gar nicht möglich.
Ich habe schon etwas Ausdauer.
- Ja.
Dann merkt man:
"Ich glaube, er mag mich."
"Was mache ich jetzt?"
Das könnte sein.
- Scheisse.
Ja.
Das ist lustig. Aber ja ...
So ist es.
- Einmal Opfer, nicht immer Opfer.
Es war harte Kost,
was wir in den Gesprächen
mit Gewaltbetroffenen erfahren haben.
Das ist uns bewusst.
Umso schöner, dass Sie sich
darauf eingelassen haben.
Wir haben auch gehört, dass es
fast immer eine Möglichkeit gibt,
Schritt für Schritt über
das erlebte Unrecht hinwegzukommen.
Danke vielmals für Ihr Interesse.
Einen schönen Abend.
Für mich ist die Zeit vorbei.
Das Kapitel ist abgeschlossen.
Jetzt geht es weiter im Leben.
Daran habe ich Freude.
Sind Sie stolz auf ihn?
- Ja.- Ja, sehr stolz.
Was kann man machen,
wenn jemand gemobbt wird?
Das Kind, das gemobbt wird,
unterstützen und helfen.
Man kann sich auch die Hand geben
und sich entschuldigen.
Ja.
Wenn ich zu lange hier oben bin
und ihm auf die Nerven gehe ...
... sagt er:
"Tschau, geh nach Hause!"
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022